In the U.S., about a third
of adults aren't getting
enough sleep.
That's defined as less
than seven hours per night.
For teenagers,
that number is over 70%.
But if you turn on the TV
and look at the way
that we talk about sleep,
you can kind of see why.
- Rich people don't sleep!
- My wife was so good,
I didn't want to sleep!
I slept for two, three hours
a night and I had a blast.
I feel like I function fine
on four to five hours of sleep.
When things get really intense,
I don't have time to go home
and shower and change,
so I just sleep here.
We live with this bizarre
culture around sleep,
and I think I get enough of it
in spite of that.
But I want to
better understand
what's happening
to my body when I don't.
So what happens to us
when we lose sleep?
And why do so many of us
struggle to get enough of it?
( alarm beeping )
( theme music playing )
So, for the past few weeks,
I've been recording
my sleep data
with a fitness tracker.
But to take that
to the next level,
I just picked up
an at home sleep test
that'll really
help me determine
just how healthy
my sleep actually is.
So this kit is going
to monitor five things--
the air coming out of my nose,
my brain activity,
my blood oxygen level,
my chest movements,
and my heart rate.
I really feel like I'm going
into the matrix right now.
This is gonna be really
uncomfortable to sleep tonight,
which I think is the part
I'm most nervous about.
Only when I've done
all five things
will all of those lights
light up.
I'm struggling
with this whole thing.
There we go. It's all green.
You see that?
It is 12:28.
I think I'm gonna try
to go to sleep
and see how this goes.
Good morning.
Oh, my God.
Um, where do I start?
That was tough.
Very uncomfortable to sleep
with all of this stuff on.
Part of me is worried
because it wasn't a very normal
representative night
of sleep.
So, the next step for me
is I take this thing
to a sleep doctor
in New York,
Dr. Mayank Shukla,
and he tells me exactly
how healthy my sleep is.
- Hello. How's it going?
- Hi. Good morning.
Thank you for coming in today.
I guess you are here
for your sleep test result.
How do you feel about
the night that you were putting
the sleep test device on
compared to all of the,
you know, nights that
you've been sleeping?
Yeah, it went okay.
It felt a little hard to sleep
with all of this stuff on.
I've been keeping track and
I can show you the spreadsheet.
- Like, a few basic metrics.
- Yes.
And usually I'm getting--
I think average for a weekday
is about 8.06 or something.
And then average for
a weekend is about 8.35.
Clearly, it looks like
that you are a reasonably
very healthy person
and you do take care
of your sleep very well.
- Mm-hmm.
- But it turns out that you
have mild sleep apnea.
So five to 15 times an hour
when someone stops breathing,
we say it's mild sleep apnea.
So if we can say it's 4.7--
- So I'm stopping
breathing 4.7--
- 4.7 times an hour.
Your numbers are slightly
above the normal.
For that particular night,
your total number
that you stopped breathing
is around 41 times
during the night.
It's shocking to hear that
I stopped breathing 41 times
in this relatively
short night of sleep.
When you stop breathing,
your sleep phase changes.
It means this
is fragmented sleep.
When you have fragmented sleep,
many times the patient
does feel sleepy, tired,
or less energetic.
Just how big of a problem
is sleep loss?
Every time that you are
disrupting your sleep cycle,
you are interrupting
your biological clock as well.
And with there's a disruption,
the chaos starts.
And that chaos leads
to mental health issues,
to cardiovascular
health issues.
And it really starts
the aging process
much more faster.
Everybody has to be in sync
to live a healthy life.
Okay. Um, this is what
my night of sleep looked like.
You can see me moving through
the four phases of sleep.
There is light sleep,
and then deep sleep
or slow wave sleep,
and then these
five chunks of REM
or rapid eye movement sleep.
That's the phase
during which we dream.
I was not expecting
to be diagnosed
with a mild sleep disorder
going into this story,
but it does make we want
to better understand
what Dr. Shukla mentioned
about this idea
of being in sync
with your biological clock.
Everybody has a specific
bodily schedule
that determines
when they should go to sleep
and when they should wake up.
It's called our chronotype.
I wanted to figure out
what mine was.
It turns out there are
online quizzes you can take
or genetic tests
that you can take,
but there's also a much simpler
way to figure it out.
( Skype ringing )
- Hello.
- Hello!
- How's it going?
- It's going well, man.
How are you?
I have a request for you
and it's gonna potentially
be weird and scary.
I want you to try
for one week
to turn off
your alarm entirely
and go to bed
when you're tired
and then wake up
when you are rested,
- but no alarm clock.
- That sounds amazing.
This is the best task
I've ever been given.
That's my main assignment
for you for this week.
- All right, man.
I'll see you in a week.
- Bye.
So it's about 8 AM
and I just woke up.
I like the safety net
of having an alarm clock.
I slept with anxiety
all night long.
I woke up at 7:30,
way earlier than I usually do.
My bedtime is kind of going
later and later
as this experiment goes on.
Can you have a chronotype
where you actually
just go to sleep
at 2 AM every day?
I keep waking up
way earlier than I planned on
getting out of bed.
So I do feel like
I'm sleeping more.
I feel like
I'm sleeping better.
It's really nice
not to have an alarm.
I'm really enjoying not having
an alarm to wake me up.
I don't know what I'm supposed
to be learning about
throughout this experience
or what it's supposed to do,
but I'm exhausted.
Well, today was the last day
of the no alarm experiment.
Spoiler alert,
I am not a morning person.
I feel a little embarrassed
because I've missed
our 10 AM meeting
pretty much every day
of this experiment.
- Cool.
- What is this?
So this is a big model
of the circadian rhythm.
This is the process
that our bodies go through
every 24 hours
like clockwork.
So what I would love to do
is just plot out
when we went to bed
and when we woke up
on average
for the past week.
- Should we do it?
- Let's do it.
I went to bed on average
at, like, 12:17
and woke up at about 8:45.
Lee:
That's very precise.
Mine was probably
around midnight,
and then I was getting up
every day around 8:00.
Joss: And I'm the night owl
of the bunch, I guess.
My average bedtime
was about 1:26,
and my average wake time
was 10:20.
- I'm so lazy.
- Let's go through it.
Right about when you wake up,
your body starts
to release cortisol.
You have the sharpest rise
in blood pressure of the day,
and you stop producing
a the hormone melatonin.
And these things all together,
those wake us up
and start us into the day.
- Daytime.
So then intestinal movement
begins for the day.
The morning poop-- biologically
scheduled into your day.
- Right after
that 8 AM coffee.
- Right, exactly.
After that, your body is at
its peak alertness of the day.
Then there's this blank gap.
It's the afternoon slump.
A few hours later,
your body has its best
coordination of the day,
followed by its quickest
reaction time.
Olympic athletes, for example,
have their highest odds
of beating a record
if they are
performing the sport
exactly within this window.
We near sunset,
and then your blood pressure
reaches its daily peak
followed by peak
body temperature.
So all of our bodies
are doing this
on this 24-hour cycle,
But in terms of how that relates
to our time and our clock,
it can vary from person
to person?
Yeah. Your body is probably
most alert at 1 PM,
whereas mine is probably
most alert at noon
and Lee's is probably most
alert closer to 11 AM.
If you are a night owl,
this entire cascade of events
shifts forward in time.
And if you're an early bird,
it shifts back in time.
And then it's night.
Your body starts
to produce melatonin
getting you ready for bed.
A few hours into sleeping,
you fall into
your deepest sleep,
and then you fall into
your lowest body temperature.
And that's it.
That's the whole cycle.
And when we don't
follow that schedule,
especially when
we cut sleep short,
we're derailing every other
thing in the cycle.
So, this chart shows
the distribution of chronotypes.
And the way that
they measure that
is by looking at
the mid-sleep time
on free days.
So you'll see that
for most people,
their midpoint is about 4 AM,
which means that
they're sleeping from, like--
- This is assuming
they sleep eight hours?
- Yeah.
But for the majority
of people,
getting to, like,
an 8 or 9 AM job,
means waking up before
their body is ready.
- Wow.
- Where that gets
really concerning
is with the health impacts
of this distribution.
The later
that midsleep time is,
the higher the rates
of depression,
of people who smoke,
and of people
who consume alcohol.
If it's the majority of us
who are suffering,
why are we doing this?
When we have a world
that is so preferential
towards early birds
and geared towards
productivity
in the morning,
the people who don't fit in
to that really suffer.
Yeah.
Christophe:
So you study the sleep-wake
cycles that control
every living thing
in the world.
What do you think are
some of the big things
that you wish people
understood better
about their ability to get
a good night of sleep?
Our genome and almost every gene
in our genome is programmed
to turn on and turn off
at a certain time
of the day or night.
So that means
we are programmed to sleep
a certain number of hours.
When we follow these rhythms,
our body can perform
at its peak performance
during the daytime
and can reset, repair,
and regenerate at nighttime
when we go to sleep.
So that means
when we don't sleep,
it actually has huge cascading
bad effects on our kidney,
liver, gut, intestine, heart,
even our skin, how we look.
Right. Beauty sleep.
We can figure out how to
be the master of our own clock
by adopting very simple
lifestyle changes
such as when to wake up,
when to turn on and turn off
your bright light,
when to eat,
and when to stop eating.
In a very simple sense,
if you have the same schedule
every single day,
or at least five
to six days in a week,
that itself
is a very powerful way
to be in control
of your circadian rhythm.
I mean,
all this is so fascinating
because a lot of us
think that we can sleep
whenever we want,
but it sounds like the body
is a whole lot less flexible
than we think it might be.
This whole idea that we can
have 24/7 food delivery,
24/7 drug stores
and grocery stores,
those are all based on
the simple idea
that we can take our body
for a spin at any given time
of the day or night.
And it's becoming
more and more clear
that if you don't have control
over when you work,
then you also don't have control
over how much you sleep.
It has come to a point that
the World Health Organization
has now designated shift work
as a carcinogen.
- Wow.
- Just imagine, just doing
shift work is the same
as getting exposed
to cancer-causing chemicals
in the environment.
And that's very profound.
That says how important sleep
and circadian rhythms are.
So, shift work can be so bad
for the human body
that it's been classified
as a carcinogen.
But it's not a problem
that everybody has to
deal with equally.
In the U.S., white people
are overrepresented
among those who start work
at around 7 and 8 AM.
Black and LatinX people are
overrepresented among workers
who start
in the early morning.
And black people are
especially overrepresented
among those who start work
late at night.
I'm on my way right now to talk
to Dr. Giradin Jean-Louis.
He's a professor at NYU who
studies the health consequences
of this racial sleep gap.
Can you sort of
paint a picture
of what sleep
health disparities
look like in the U.S.?
Who gets to sleep well in
this country and who doesn't?
What we have been seeing
over the last 50 years
is that there's a disparity
between blacks and white
in terms of how much
sleep they get.
And we're finding
that blacks overall
seem to be sleeping
about 30 minutes less.
And of course that
would have repercussions.
You're gonna be at
greater risk of obesity,
for diabetes, hypertension,
and now we've seen
the same is true
for Alzheimer's, dementia.
Can you walk me
through the factors
that are particularly hitting
black Americans the hardest?
Well, socioeconomic factors,
environmental factors,
psychosocial factors.
So, for instance, if you
find that in a community
perceived racism is an issue,
well, it's going to
affect your sleep.
If you happen to be in
an environment where there's
quite a bit of noise,
it's gonna affect your sleep.
If you have light pollution,
air pollution,
all of those factors
can influence your sleep.
And we also find that
there are a lot of black folks
that are working two jobs.
So the ability to actually
set a schedule--
you're gonna go to bed
at the same time,
wake up at the same time,
which is critically important--
they don't have that luxury.
So this is a map
of short sleep duration
by census tract,
so this is where people are
getting less than seven hours
of sleep per night regularly.
Can you help me understand
why this map looks
the way it does?
All the areas that are dark
suggest that these are folks
who are having significant
problems sleeping.
And as we get lighter
and lighter, these are people
that are doing okay.
So what you want to see
is communities like this
seem to be doing well,
whereas communities
like this or like that
are not doing so well.
And why is that important?
Because the higher the
prevalence of short sleepers,
the more likely you're
going to be seeing obesity,
high blood pressure,
diabetes, and to some degree,
cardiovascular disease,
stroke,
and myocardial infarction.
What we also note
is if you're looking at
the obesity belt,
this section also is where
most people happen to be obese.
- Hmm.
- So there seems to be
direct correlation
between obesity
and poor sleep.
So it seems like the places
that really stand out to me
are in the southeast,
all along the Mississippi
in the south here,
this Kentucky-
West Virginia cluster.
Those are really
the deepest reds,
not to mention
also right here,
which are Native American
reservations.
So here's what's
interesting now.
When we're looking
at COVID data,
we find that a lot
of those people that are
infected with COVID
happen to be in the same area
with people having short sleep.
So we know what's
happening here is that
if you're not sleeping enough,
your immune system
is compromised,
so you're more likely
to get a COVID-19 infection
and die as a result of it.
It sounds like sleep
is a basic need
that in a lot of ways
has been turned
into a privilege.
If your circadian rhythms
are not robust,
the ability to fight off
certain diseases,
your ability to remain
metabolically healthy
is significantly compromised
because the circadian clock
controls biological rhythms.
So when you bring
those two factors together,
it makes it absolutely
difficult for a black person
to actually stay healthy.
( vibrating )
You know, at least
for the past few decades,
there's never been, like,
a shortage of things
to wake you up,
things to
put you back to sleep.
The truth is
that for most of my life,
I haven't had
that much control over
when I needed to wake up.
If we want
to address sleep loss
as the public
health problem that it is,
we have to do it through
structural changes
and policy changes,
not just through
individual changes.
There are some policies
that we know can make
a difference.
So the first example has to do
with how we schedule work.
In 2015,
there was this fascinating
real world experiment
conducted on
a steel factory in Germany.
Basically, all the workers
normally would cycle through
three different shifts.
There was a morning shift
that was from 6 AM to 2 PM,
an evening shift
that was 2 PM to 10 PM,
and then a night shift
that was 10 PM to 6 AM.
- Got it.
- So they would cycle
two days of each
and then a couple
days off in between.
Two days of each?
Like, they could never
establish a routine?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oof.
On this chart,
each one of these
is basically a morning person,
someone whose chronotype
is very skewed early.
Each one of these is someone
who has an average chronotype.
And then each of these
is a late chronotype.
So, a night owl.
Very late sleeper.
Then researchers came in,
and what they did
is they basically reassigned
shifts by chronotype.
So every single late sleeper
was made to never work
the morning shift.
And then every early bird
was made to never have
to work the night shift.
And the results were really,
really fascinating.
So for both
the early chronotypes
and the late chronotypes,
sleep duration
on workdays went up,
sleep quality went up,
and their well-being
on workdays went up.
- This looks really positive.
- There's a really strong
case that employers
should help their employees
sleep according
to their chronotypes.
It makes a huge difference
on their physical health,
their mental health,
their productivity,
their happiness.
And you do see different
versions of this catching on.
Southwest Airlines
apparently lets pilots choose
between an AM schedule
versus a PM schedule.
For a lot of these jobs,
it's about safety of
everyone else around them.
When I look at this,
I think the time in my life
when I was most
schedule constrained
was when I was in school.
Are schools doing
anything different now?
Yeah. These same chronotype
optimizing benefits
are very apparent
in school start time.
So this is roughly what
the adolescent chronotype
looks like.
The average teen
needs between eight to ten
hours of sleep.
And then this is what
the average school schedule
looks like.
The American Academy of
Pediatrics suggests
that school should never
start before 8:30.
So it's really this overlap
that is just wreaking havoc
on the teenage body.
They're doing calculus
during their sleep schedule.
Mm-hmm, entirely.
So we're requiring kids to
basically come into school
way before their bodies
are ready for it.
There have been dozens
of studies looking
at what happens when
you try to fix this.
Delaying start times is
associated with an increase
in sleep duration,
improved attendance,
better grades,
better graduation rates,
lower rates of depression,
and even fewer
motor vehicle crashes.
It's a long list
of really good things
from just one extra hour
of sleep in the morning.
You just listed everything
that's important for teenagers.
- Yeah.
- It feels like parents
should care a lot
- about making this change.
- Yeah.
Also, I gotta say,
it doesn't seem like
the hardest change
in the world to make.
And these are just
a start, right?
This is just the beginning
of what a world
that takes chronotype into
account when it comes to work,
when it comes
to scheduling, everything,
what that world
could look like.
It doesn't necessarily
sound easy,
but it does sound
incredibly worth it.
I started this story
hoping to figure out
why so many people struggle
to get a good night's sleep.
And the answer
that I'm left with
is kind of frustrating.
You know, getting
the right amount of sleep
at the right time
for your circadian clock,
it's one of the most important
things that you can do
for your body.
Sleep is foundational.
Anything in life requires
a good night's sleep.
So if you're
not sleeping enough,
everything is really on hold.
But the thing is,
our schedules and our habits
and our culture
and our environments,
all those things get
in the way of us doing so.
But when we trivialize sleep,
we're basically pretending
that our biological limits
matter a lot less
than they actually do.
Public policy, workplace policy,
school policy,
all these policies
have to change so that
we can have a more coherent
and synergistic effort going on
throughout the society
to nurture
our circadian rhythms.
Does that mean that my takeaway
is that we all need
to turn off our alarm clocks
and sleep whenever we want?
No, obviously not.
But there are thing that
we can do to help the people
suffering the most
from sleep loss to have
the time and the flexibility
to get rest when they need it.
I think that's
a good place to start.
I feel like I am not
gonna have the greatest
night of sleep.
Oh, I don't like that.
So about two hours
after you wake up,
- that's when you
should go to the gym?
- Mm-hmm.
That's interesting
information.
Not for me, obviously,
but for other people.